Speaker 1: Let's go next to why don't we try
Mitch from Toronto, Canada?
Mitch, you are on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me?
I can hear you fine, yeah.
Speaker 2: OK, great.
Longtime listener, I actually just became
a member the other day.
Great.
Love your program!
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
For sure.
So I don't know if you follow anything going
on in Canada, but what I wanted to ask you
about was more, I guess, cross-border anyway.
And it has to do with the environment and.
Kind of like where things are going in the
future in terms of gas prices are getting
crazy up here in Canada, at least in Ontario.
They're getting crazy and I think they're
getting pretty expensive in the US as well.
What are your thoughts on like moving people
to electric cars subsidizing that?
And if you have any thoughts on like how that
how that's playing in with with home ownership,
condo or otherwise, I would love to hear your
thoughts on that kind of scenario.
Speaker 1: Let me I'll get back to the second
part.
Yes.
I mean, listen.
Gas prices are going up.
They are not at historic highs, but they are
higher.
I am a huge advocate of electric cars.
I've had one now for over a year.
I think that there's an incredible double
standard where you have the very same people
complaining about high gas prices and blaming
them on Biden want to prevent Biden from doing
more on building an electric vehicle charging
network and subsidizing electric vehicles,
incentivizing electric vehicles, et cetera,
et cetera.
We have some subsidies at the state and some
at the federal level for electric cars.
It's not nearly enough.
So if you want to solve the gas price problem,
let's get off of gas.
That's number one.
Number two in terms of the homeownership and
condo thing.
I listen to a very interesting podcast recently,
which basically says the path forward is we
need government to subsidize retrofitting.
You go building by building structure, by
structure and you put solar panels on the
roof or in the yard, depending on whether
it's urban rural, you replace and retrofit
heating systems to be modern, ultra efficient.
Often they are heat pump mini split systems,
although there are many other ways that there's
not just one system, but you know, we got
to get off of burning oil for heating.
Certainly, baseboard electric is like one
of the least efficient.
It's a disaster.
You replace stoves with ultra efficient new
electric, and I love gas as much as the next
person.
But in this way you create each building takes
in solar power, has the most efficient electric
elements for cooking and heating, and you've
got a car charger, so you're charging the
car with the Sun.
This is the process.
You've just got to start doing it.
You've got you've got to start going building
by building.
Governments got to figure out how to do it.
We got to get off this gasoline stuff.
We just have to.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What is that podcast?
I'm curious where you're getting some of your
information.
Speaker 1: I wish I remembered what it was.
I just don't.
No problem.
Let me see if you'd let me give me.
Give me one second.
Let me see if it's still in my Spotify history.
I'm just looking at it on my own.
Speaker 2: You're looking.
I'm also curious what kind of electric car
you've been driving.
Speaker 1: I've been driving a Tesla.
Speaker 2: OK, you've been driving your Tesla
now.
Are you driving the lake, the van sedan?
I think that's the Model X.
Are you on the Model S?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't want to say specifically
because the vehicle is kind of conspicuous,
you know?
Yeah.
Um, I don't, you know, it might have been
it might have been brain stuff, but I don't
know.
I don't know what the podcast was.
But in any case, in
Speaker 2: the winter, how do you find it
in the winter?
Speaker 1: Well, the thing with electric vehicles
is when you use the battery to run the heat
pump to heat the car.
It does consume significantly more battery,
so the range is notably decreased in the winter.
It's never been a problem, particularly with
the supercharging network and a high speed
charger at home.
It's never caused a problem for me.
But there's trips where in the summer I might
finish the trip at 40 percent, where I'm rolling
in, at 22 percent in winter, if I'm running
the heat at 70 or something like that.
Speaker 2: That's good to know.
Yeah.
Thanks so much for taking my call.
I really appreciate it, and I would love to
hear more of your thoughts on this kind of
stuff on your program at any point if you
decide to cover it.
I'm really interested in in some of the more
granular stuff around this and would love
to hear more of your thoughts.
Speaker 1: All right, I very much appreciate
the call.
Thanks so much, David.
All right.
Take care, guys.
Pretty solid calls today so far.
Let's not ruin it.
Please, please, nobody ruin it.
Why don't we go next to Brett from I believe
it's Indiana.
Is that right, Brett?
Correct me, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: All right, perfect.
Hold on a second.
I've got to go for discreet.
Sorry.
Speaker 1: Oh, that discretion is key with
many of these calls, right?
Speaker 3: I'm at school, so I don't want
to offend anybody.
But anyway, so two questions and I'll be quick,
please.
So, so for me, as a National Guard member,
do you think it would be cheaper if the U.S.
spent more on the National Guard as compared
to active duty?
I don't know.
I don't know if you're informed on that or
not.
I just was curious as to your thoughts on
that.
Speaker 1: I don't know enough about that
to comment substantively, to be honest.
Speaker 3: Or I understand.
I mean, it's just if we spent more domestically,
it's certainly mathematically could save more
because, you know, we wouldn't have to spend
money sending them to another country and
we would could focus on domestic issues, you
know, because there are like military jobs
where like they do something as simple as
work on railroad tracks or, you know, you
know, washers and dryers, you know, there's
even combat medics.
But that's just my view.
Speaker 1: It's an interesting question.
I will look into it.
Speaker 3: I appreciate it.
So do you know?
So here's my last question.
Do you know if there's what the infrastructure
bill that Biden just signed?
Yeah, there is a possibility of magnetic trains
being included into it or because I tried
to look into that and I didn't see anything
about it.
Speaker 1: So I know that there's a there's
a designation of money specifically for rail.
And there's also a designation for public
transit.
And both of those things can touch train travel.
I don't know.
Let me put it this way I haven't seen anything
about maglev trains specifically, but that
doesn't mean it is in there or it isn't in
there.
I just haven't seen it at that level of granularity.
Speaker 3: Right, because when I was in Paris,
I went from Paris to Madrid on a magnetic
train, I was very impressed by the speed.
I was like, Wow,
Speaker 1: holy crap, I like you.
Did you say Madrid?
Yeah, Metro does Paris.
Are you talking about Madrid, Spain?
Yeah, I like that, I've never heard it pronounced
Madrid, but I sort of like it.
Speaker 3: Well, it depends on what language
I'm speaking, so if I'm speaking Spanish,
I'll say it like Madrid, but if I'm speaking
that to like, you know, an English speaker,
I'll say it as Madrid.
Speaker 1: Hey, listen, if it's work now,
I love it.
If it's working for you.
Keep going.
I like it.
Speaker 3: All righty.
I appreciate your time.
All right,
Speaker 1: thanks.
There's Brett from Indianapolis, dropping
in a variety
of
different opinions, questions, comments, et
cetera.